سياق الجدل بشان تزويد كيف بدبابات
ليوبارد قال رئيس الوزراء الهولندي ماتيوس
مرافسكي ان بلاده لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي
بينما تنزف اوكرانيا وشدد على ان من سماهم
المدافعين الاوكرانيين عن اوروبا يحتاجون
الى الدبابات على الفور واكد مرافسكي في
مقابله صحفيه ان بلاده مستعده لبناء تحالف
صغير من الدول المستعده لتسليم بعض
دباباتها الحديثه الى اوكرانيه في حال لم
يكن هناك اتفاق مع المانيا بشان دبابات
وانتقدا مرافسكي تردد المانيا بهذا الشان
وقال ان اوكرانيا واوروبا ستنتصران في
الحرب حتى من دون برلين واصفا موقفها من
نتيجه اجتماع رمشتاين بغير المقبولين
في اثناء نقره صحيفه بلد الالمانيه عن
وزير الدفاع الالماني بولس بالسوريوس انه
سيزور اوكرانيا في اقرب فرصه ممكنه وقال
باستور يوسن برلين تجري حوارا وثيقا مع
شركائها الدوليين خاصه واشنطن بشان تسليم
دبابات ليبردو اوكرانيا بنيت الاستعداد
جيدا للقرارات المحتمله